for coming in here today for
this little interview
slash audition
slash you're hired.
Flavia, we of
course know
each other from our
last project,
thank you so much for flying
yourself in from Brazil.
And Amy, welcome.
Thank you.
How'd you find out about
this little project ?
I saw it in a--an ad
in a magazine.
It just said,
"Actress slash models
for marketing viral
video" ?
Yeah, yeah, that's our ad in
"Stage Couch," fantastic.
Well, Flavia, I mean,
this is gonna
be a little
old hat for you,
but let me give Amy here
a quick rundown.
In a nutshell, it's
a marketing video.
We're calling it
"Two Girls, One Cup."
And we're hoping it
goes viral.
It opens on you
and Flavia naked,
kissing each other over
some soft piano music.
Nothing too intense,
just some light kissing.
Then Amy, you're
gonna stand up and spread
your cheeks and shit
into a cup.
Then both of you will
lick the shit out of the cup,
spread it all over your
faces and then kiss
each other some more
with shit on your face.
Next, Flavia, you're gonna blow
some bubbles with the shit
and then Amy, you're gonna
sit on a dildo while Flavia
vomits the shit into
your mouth,
then you vomit the shit
back into Flavia's mouth,
then Flavia re-vomits
that shit one more time
back into your mouth.
Yeah, that's it,
the end.
Just one quick
question.
Will we be using
some sort
of a CGI effect or,
like, stage chocolate.
No, you'll be eating
a full cup of real shit.
No fancy special
effects here.
We're indie, you know,
so it's super low budge.
Size-wise, are we
talking a teacup ?
16-ounce glass.
Is this, like,
gonna be an art film ?
Like it might wind
up in the MoMA ?
No.
But it's like commentary,
it's kind of meta, you know,
like that scene in "American
Beauty" with the plastic bag.
No, I haven't seen
that movie.
Well, the image, it's
a plastic bag whirling around
in the wind, it was
kind of like--
Is it a bag of shit ?
No.
Then no.
Is it art ?
It's scat porn.
It's basically
the opposite of art.
You won't see
our faces.
Oh, we will definitely
see both your faces.
But they'll be, um,
blurred, you know ?
The blur effect, or like a black
bar when it's like, over our--
I mean, they'll have
dark shit on them.
There's gonna be
shit on our eyes ?
Will we be tested for
diseases beforehand ?
No, we use the
honor system here.
Flavia knows the drill.
( speaking foreign language )
Yeah, see.
You guys are gonna be
viral video stars, huh ?
Who's ready ?
Yay !
What do you say ?
Yeah.
I'll do it,
I'll do it.
I definitely need more
on-camera experience, so.
You're gonna get
it right now.
There's one
little hitch.
We need you to definitely
lose some weight.
And I'm thinking,
ballpark, three, five pounds.
That's a lot of weight.
Mainly in the face.
Maybe I'll just lose it
the day of into the cup.
That's gross, Amy.
She's eating.